I think it comes down to equality,
um,
which is I think such a silly thing to
say in 2008,
um,
but I think it comes down to sort of
civil rights,
the right to get married,
the right to file your taxes together,
hospital visitation rights,
um,
and,
and I think beyond that is equality
including in the military with don't
ask,
don't tell,
which seems to always be a hot button
issue that pops up,
uh,
you know,
once a year or so,
but especially now with the presidential
debate,
uh,
and uh,
candidates taking a aside on the issue.
Um,
but I,
I think it comes down to basic civil
rights
because I think it remains even among
people who claim to support gay rights.
I think it remains a taboo subject in
that while if we're saying the majority
of America has no problem with gay
people,
I think that there's an asterisk that
position no problem with gay people so
long as you're not my son as long as
you're not my sister.
Um,
and I,
and I think the idea of introducing that
and into one's personal life,
um,
whether people will own up to it or not
remains an issue.
I think it's very easy from the bubble
of New York or la just say,
you know,
this should be a nonissue,
but there so much,
so many opinions and views in between
those coasts that don't necessarily
agree with that.
And I think it's very clear that I'm a
evangelical and a very conservative
religious groups,
uh,
maintain quite a bit of power in this
country because there are,
you know,
it's very clear that candidates are,
are leaning one way or the other one
when it comes to their approach of them.
And there are viewpoints,
uh,
have to be taken seriously on the
political spectrum.
Uh,
and that's,
you know,
it's there that these things are going
to change.
I have,
I have a,
I have a personal issue with,
with the idea that some people can
tolerate homosexuality.
Um,
I do not tolerate women.
I do not tolerate black or Asian people.
Uh,
I embraced them as they would anyone
else.
And so I think right now we're sending
this message of a tolerance and I think
it is a stepping stone toward embracing
or even so much so that it's a nonissue.
Um,
I,
I think right now the goal needs to be,
um,
to,
to promote this as a normalized a sort
of behavior.
And I think that if we're taking these
sort of bandaid or sideways approaches
to get to a final result,
we're going to end up with something
that's still not viewed very well.
So the,
I think the message we need to be
pitching is,
um,
this sort of normalized behavior.
Gay people are just like straight
people.
They just leap with the same sex.
I mean,
that's really all it comes down to.
I think it's easier for me to say that's
such a simple message,
not only because I live in a very urban
area,
but I'm a gay man.
Uh,
you know,
on the same token,
I don't think it's very easy for,
um,
you know,
other folks in more conservative parts
of the country,
uh,
to accept that message.
You know,
I'm a little bit torn there because I
think Hollywood shouldn't necessarily be
a platform for any message,
but then I also believe it's foolish to
imagine that it doesn't,
um,
you know,
from,
from the very basic of cutting out
smoking for movies and what that did to
views toward people who smoke.
Um,
you know,
I think we're moving beyond,
I like to think the token gay character
in movies and TV shows,
um,
but I don't think we're quite there yet,
but I think that's important to show
that,
uh,
even in mainstream movies to have gay
and lesbian characters who are
normalized,
they're not the token gay character.
They are another character in that
movie.
Um,
and I,
and I liked the idea of sort of a plot
lines within a TV and film that deal
with gay men and women,
but don't necessarily focus on that as a
sole issue because then I,
I think it sort of creates a caricature
of what this is supposed to be.
So I,
I do think to an extent,
Hollywood does hold some responsibility,
but,
uh,
you know,
homophobia exists in that industry like
any other,
um,
while you know your agent or your
publicist can be gay,
uh,
don't expect to sign on to a movie as an
open gay person a and an expected big
paycheck.
It's very easy for me to,
as a movie goer to say Hollywood.
The institution needs to change their
ways.
But I also think if they've put a,
a openly gay character in a,
in a major motion picture,
uh,
I don't think it would perform as well
as the bar at the box office.
So I think we do need to take small
steps to reach that end all goal.
It's not going to happen overnight.
And I think it'd be foolish to assume
so.
But,
um,
you know,
I think the American public does still
have this cringe mentality when it comes
to the idea of gay men and women playing
leading roles or roles where they aren't
the gay character,
uh,
all the way to Hollywood that is fearful
of even opening up that possibility
because the investment is so large.
And,
uh,
in a studio wants to make that bet.